[Musique]
commissariat de caen au deuxième étage
on y va l'équipe de la brigade de
protection de la famille
à citer un grand
je laisse ouvert si un souci je suis là
derrière chaque porte se cache un secret
votre sexe est pas sorti par l'opération
du saint-esprit de votre pantalon vous
êtes d'accord
aujourd'hui vous êtes là parce que vous
vouliez aller lacéré la gueule quand
même pas compliqué vous comprenez là
alors
vous savez un bébé dans les bras votre
reflex et pas de faire ça vote réflexes
et un ca
les gars de protection des familles
bonjour
ces drames sont le quotidien de virginie
mickaël stephan et de leur chef francis
et laurent
[Musique]
est parti pendant six mois nous avons
suivi le travail de ces cinq policiers
par terre c'est dégueulasse au mur on
est là aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya une
histoire de délaissement mineurs
perquisition saviez pas fait tout ça
interrogatoires
confrontation
leur mission dénouer les affaires de
famille
[Musique]
ce matin laurent a convoqué la brigade
pour un cas de violence conjugale
hier soir cette femme est venue déposer
plainte contre son ex conjointe pour
coups et blessures il lui aurait
tailladé le visage alors qu'elle venait
récupérer leur fils de trois ans laurent
confie l'enquète à stéphane
stéphanie va pas traiter tout seul parce
que bon c'est des dossiers il faut être
plusieurs à traiter donc voilà avons
tout fait mme annie valy ce qu'on
appelle un directeur gérer le dossier et
puis après effectivement on n'est pas
trop d'être quatre pour que chacun
ça y est les parties là il est allé dans
son bureau il va lire il faut laisser au
calme et après hop j'ai pointé le bout
de mon nez jédir alors tu as lu qu'est
ce que tu veux pas qu'on fasse en tête
et là ça va se dérouler tout seul
depuis quatre ans à la brigade stéphane
a traité des dizaines d'histoires de
violence entre époux
c'est sur son histoire de couple mais on
a quand même affaire à quelqu'un qui a
tailladé visage de sa femme
ça souffre d'aucune négligence ce truc
là et autant pour nous ça va être la
sphère de deux jours aux trois jours
autant pour elle ça va être entre
guillemets la faire de sa vie en tout
cas une des affaires de sa vie parce que
ça elle va le traîner jusqu'à sa mort la
pauvre dame
besoin
la victime arrive à l'hôtel de police et
c'est virginie qui l'accueille
[Musique]
mélanie à 25 ans elle vient faire
constater ses blessures
cette entaille située à quelques
millimètres de la carotide aurait pu lui
être fatale
séparée depuis quelques mois mélanie
explique qu'elle a vécu neuf années de
vie de couple marqué par la violence et
les menaces ce à commencer par un coude
d'aller casser sur la tête et ça finit à
la lame de cutter
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
d'amour
c'est bête hein
mais c'était ça
l'amour était plus fort du coup oui bah
on se dit il va changer
parce qu'après il ya quand même entre
guillemets des bons moments mais on y va
changer il va se remettre dans le droit
chemin et a pas recommencer et en fait
non il recommence tout le temps
l'ex compagnon de la victime est
toujours en liberté avant de
l'interpeller stéphane décide de se
rendre sur les lieux de l'agression
michael et virginie l'accompagnent
allez collègues
après les radars
dans l'équipe chaque policier à sa
manière de procéder
ce qui caractérise les enquêtes de
stéphane qu'on peut l'aider c'est sur la
bonne humeur la détente
pas du tout
non on se sent bien
voilà
l'agression a eu lieu dans cet immeuble
mickaël stephan et virginie veulent
comprendre ce qui s'est passé hier après
midi dans ce hall
[Musique]
je pense que là et là tant
il est caché que c'est juste écrit sur
[Musique]
le ménage a été fait mais il reste
encore des traces de l'agression
ça
c'est la police
donc apparemment ça a crié ça a gueulé
un peu ça a été assez virulent comme
échanger jouer savoir si vous avez vu ou
entendu quelque chose non pas du tout
vous n'avez pas vu de couteau de marteau
de n'avait rien contre 70
et hier n'ai pas vu non plus vers le
haut des traces de sang vous dire comme
ça vous avez entendu des bruits de les
paroles des choses comme ça oui mais je
peux pas ne pas dire quoi parce que j'ai
pas entendu j'entends dixie d'horizon
décrivent l'homme qu'ils recherchent
habite à quelques mètres les enquêteurs
vont vérifier s'il n'est pas chez lui
vous convient bon on peut voir deux
minutes c'est son pied de son immeuble
par hasard il croit son frère
[Musique]
si tu te couches cependant il
s'est bonifié
votre frère je sais combien le suspect
se rend sans résister
explique
stéphane décide de perquisitionner son
appartement pour retrouver larmes de
l'agression
vous êtes placé en garde à vue d'accord
ça marche vous vous allez vouloir voir
un avocat
oui sk possibilité de rapprocher son
patrouille à 6 soit une patrouille
section c'est surtout pour sécuriser un
peu les lieux là on est en perquisition
chez réa mise en cause mon gros proches
combat devait avoir un peu fait de mal
tu fais du mal à
comment vous allez aimer ce qu'est ce
qui s'est passé
d'accord voilà
c'est ce qu'ont cherché un marteau je
parle de marteau
[Musique]
même
la présence des policiers provoque des
tensions dans le quartier
la brigade quitter les lieux rapidement
le compte à rebours a commencé il reste
aux enquêteurs 48 heures maximum le
temps légal de la garde à vue pour
comprendre pourquoi et comment cet homme
a agressé son ex compagne
mais le corps de qu'on fait dans la vie
plus vite ça saigne plus vite c'est fini
un rang derrière ce que je me sentais
pas capable
nous avons vu tout le monde je suis une
dernière fois parce qu'on sait pas ce
qui va se passer maintenant
deux sont tellement trop gentil de suite
en une nouvelle orléans fait
en même temps est ce que je fais aussi
c'est carrément la prison je m'ouvre
c'est mon frère
parce que dans so foot mérite pas ça
ça fait trois ans
[Musique]
caraman âge continue au deuxième étage
virginie et mickaël auditionnent les
parents de l'agresseur présumé
avez vous une explication sur
une séparation qui se passe mal et
il ya vu quelque chose ou pour qu'il
fasse sa poursuite du tribunal donc
mélanie voulait va reprendre la garde de
son fils pour par rapport à certaines
choses moi je peux rien dire moi toute
façon tu un terme à ma deuxième fille
mais elle est toujours là pour moi
dans le couloir le fils du suspect
attend la fin de l'audition de ses
grands parents
[Musique]
cherchent une solution pour écarter le
petit notre mort parce que je cherchais
le papa et j'ai pas très envie qu'ils se
rencontrent en fait pas que je veuille
eux ne pas lui montrer son fiston mais
pour le vent on va pour l'audition et ça
doit pas besoin d'être plus déstabilisés
ont rajouté un peu d un peu de pression
à tout ça donc le plus même pour le tus
pas une bonne idée qui voit tout ce
monde-là d'en chercher une solution pour
m'en débarrasser
gentiment
je me suis
qu'est-ce qu'on
prend 2,3 jouer puis tu vas rentrer la
battue avec papy je te laisse
s'installer là d'accord ce que je fais
du travail de l'autre côté pu le faire
peut-être du bruit
je suis remettrait stéphane procède à la
première audition de youssef qui a
choisi d'être accompagnée d'une avocate
commise d'office est-ce que vous avez
compris pourquoi je faisais cette
audition oui elle dit que contrairement
à ce que vous expliquez elle dit pas oui
on s'est expliqué il s'énerve et m'a mis
un coup tu te dis non je rends là pour
jouer aujourd'hui elle dit je rentre
dans le hall des personnes je ne vois
personne je constate sur ma droite ni
ceux qui tout de suite nous dit tu vois
tu va m'enlever mon fils et qui met des
coups de pied
du coup plus long
si elle annonce que des marques de coups
de pieds ça à lire est mon poto comment
ce que j ai attrapé par un cocktail
motif pour le col
savez je leur venue à remonter sur la
paix
a dit que vous étiez équipé d'un marteau
ou non
[Musique]
pas de coups de pied et pas de marteau
un seul coup de cutter ou plusieurs deux
touches boucau crois que c'est ça
c'est ça c'est bien elle
voilà ça ça m'embête beaucoup voilà
je suis là et mon arc en mai très
dangereux ce qui simule une artère qui
passe il s'appelle la carotide s'ils
allaient sectionner à et ça va gicler du
sang partout elle est morte
je ne jouerai plus que vous comprenez
maintenant pourquoi je voudrais que vous
soyez superplay +5 arias laura m vous
dire plus et karine et c'est enfin c'est
édifiant oui enfin édifiant ses gaffes
et ses uvres et cesser ses propres jeux
d'hier elle a été super bien saturée
mais là est la même ce tueur est là donc
ça fait mais je trouve ça un peu plus
impressionnant vrai que ça les photos
alors
oui c'est ça marrant
ça je
hais ce que sur les faits vous avez
quelque chose à rajouter sur les crs que
youssef reconnaît en partie les faits
mais une question doit encore être
élucidées la préméditation
stéphane décide de lui lire les textos
qu'il envoie à son ex compagne depuis
deux mois voilà alors tu as cru que tu
allais me baiser si facilement prends
mon fils tu te mets un coup de rasoir
sur le visage tu te souviendras toute ta
vie tu as essayé
ça c'est 31 mai
arrêt ça fait ton anniversaire ce sera
le dernier s'est pas égaux terre en
boîte dans un cercueil bien sur ossus
boys je te tue sans hésitation cette
envie d'être en chaise roulante rhin je
vais être piétinés des figures et ce qui
me gêne un peu je vous poserai la
question je vous cache pas c'est vous
revenez souvent sur le fait des figures
et vous parce que ce match s'est passé
un truc qui pourrait sinon comment
s'appellent ces villes ont fêté leur
tâche et beaucoup d'eau pure ce2
d'importance aux visages ont fait agir
vous visez vous visez dans les menaces
j'entends oui mais voilà là où vous
pensez que ça va bien lui faire mal en
tout cas ou non depuis en fait que ce
qui peut la toucher ouais d'accord
j'en sais rien alors jamais je fais
cette promesse parce que c'est pas moi
qui ai juge parce que si c'est moi qui
jugeait je vous cache pas que ça irait
plus vite je vois pas l'intérêt c'est
dégueulasse que vous avez fait mais
c'est pas moi qui décide donc je vous
promets très rien je vais pas vous dire
que vous allez être lâchée avec les
félicitations du jury c'est pas possible
ça nous alors je suis un truc je
comprendrais pas mais voilà
[Musique]
après 1h30 d'interrogatoire youssef
reconnaît l'agression mais toujours pas
la préméditation
[Musique]
vous avez eu besoin de bousculer
psychologiquement pour le faire parler a
priori
il n'a pas besoin d'être secouée pour
pour s'expliquer toutes les photos c'est
un petit peu perturbé mais bon c'est le
jeu mais
ouais je suis anti
qu'est ce que je fais 13,6 me met un
coup d'oeil y met un coup de deux coups
de cutter à sa femme qu'est ce que je
suis soit je les exécute sur place et
demain sur à sa place je ferai plus
jamais mon boulot
soit j'essaye de faire mon boulot puis
voilà il m'expliqua le but du jeu c'est
ça c'est dégueulasse c'est dégueulasse
voilà panda après c'est plus mon boulot
on bosse l'essayer de
d'éclaircir un peu tout ça et puis quand
la lumière est faite et ben c'est aux
juges de faire
de dessiner
le procureur décide de prolonger la
garde à vue de 24 heures pour permettre
à stéphane d'organiser une confrontation
entre l'agresseur et sa victime
[Applaudissements]
les menaces et sont relativement
récentes elles sont écrites il reconnaît
[Musique]
le lendemain toute la brigade de savoir
comment c'est passé l'audition de
l'appel
à regarder et voir à prendre part à vos
réactions corps et la voix et toi
notamment après la confrontation si tu
peux toucher autant que moi mais
peut-être parce que voilà une femme par
rapport à quand tu lances au visage
voilà vous toucher beaucoup cette
histoire oui oui oui ça me touche parce
que pour moi il l'a marqué la marque et
bestialement quoi c'est l'homme qui
marque barnard monde et on en normandie
c'est on marque les bêtes quoi et ben là
c'est ça il a marqué dit toi tu auras ma
marque avis sur le visage et tout le
monde verra que tu as été ma femme en
groupe
moi ça me touche énormément
c'était femme s'apprête à recevoir la
victime pour une confrontation avec son
agresseur
confronte 14h
14h45 environ ouais tout seul
mais si tu veux je t'ai sinon je fais
mes dossiers là tu me dis moi mais ils
sont je fais pas beaucoup parlé je te
laisse
je mets 10 euros là dessus en virginie
qui dit je fais
profonde mais je te promets juin 2010
sur la table donc quoi quoi et this way
est clair c'est que tu vas terre au
début j'ai quelques questions je vois en
tête match à m comme ça rien tu va
bouillir et qu'à un moment donné tu
cherches la range la pièce que j'ai déjà
gagné clairement retenu tu vas dire si
je peux me permettre et je vais dire
mais je t'en prie et là c'est parti et
puis là après il va te regarder mais je
vais dire ministe plus par mois il pas
ce que je fait possible et cambrai comme
ça il veut connaissent bien bien venir
je veux rien dire là voyez la première
fois beaucoup et bex et ouais non je
vais épater je vais changer
d'accord
14 heures mélanie vient d'arriver avec
son avocat
dunkerque où la
cgt
[Applaudissements]
a brutalisé autrement que qu'avec une
lame
blade jamie autre chose que des dames
une bof une fois je la crois que pour
les chevaux je le ferai de chez moi et
m'a dit dégage maintenant je garde tout
est jeu de con
j'ai moins 2 milliards de dollars et
j'en avais marre du monde soit on est un
petit peu reconnaître des méchantes et
rancunes iréc tellement tenait bon et
vanessa gray donc le sable tombe tout
sur moi mais parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes là parce que vous vouliez aller la
serrer la garde quand même pas compliqué
ça je suis drame en plus vous avez un
mollet faire ensemble afin de vous en
occuper maintenant si ça à coups de
cutter dans la gueule c'est pas bon
est-ce que vous devez viser le visage
volontairement ou est-ce que vous
deux buts pour lui faire peur et à
prévost le shape et lycées
soit vous alliez
l'action
bondissant comme on aime dire pourquoi
viser le visage pour les bras pas les
genoux
la patrie le dos
auquel ce rappel
on arrête de mentir je voulait la punir
mais pas la marque et
c'est pas un peu bourru sépare aussi je
vous laisse il se rappelle c'est qu'elle
est une trace quoi bon de peau comme
sera pas trop ça avec l être
bonjour je ne le pense que la bombe
puisque paulo bogota
chacun et votre fils qui voit sa mère
comme ça qu'est ce qu'il répond
on à fait j'ai pas dit que j'avais
raison je produis que je reconnais pas
le seul du col qu'est ce que tu dis là
qu'est ce qui t'arrive maman qu'est ce
qu'il répond alors c'est un mot
tabou qu'est ce qu'elle répond bah ouais
messieurs
raison ou tort
et que votre fils a demandé
bon eh tu vois les danseurs peu importe
comment vous y êtes allé mais en tout
cas il faut aller dans cet immeuble dans
le but de la série visage d'y aller je
suis tombé dessus je le fais je
reconnais que j'ai fait que j'ai voulu
faire mais si je n'étais pas c'est pas
prémédité cgt pas de cachet et je suis
tombé voilà mais tu étais cacher tu dis
ça mais tu étais cacher son ventre on a
fait pour moi c'est prémédité des
messages que le fait que tu m'attends
dans le hall avec ton marteau thalamus
rappelle quand j'étais par terre tu me
traîner par terre
ajouter quelque chose tout est dit ou
presque tu vois je boxe tmz excuse moi
[Applaudissements]
tu m'excuses propos de moi
et moi je te pardonnerai jamais
[Musique]
youssef sera jugé le lendemain en
comparution immédiate et condamné à cinq
ans de prison dont un avec sursis et
l'interdiction de rentrer en contact
avec son ex-compagne
en france tous les trois jours une femme
meurt sous les coups de son conjoint
[Musique]
depuis qu'il a quitté la région
parisienne pour la côte normande
stéphane aime prendre le large pour se
ressource
je suis le premier flic de la famille
moi j'ai pas de vocation je me sens pas
une vocation à quoi que ce soit si ce
n'est rendre service voilà ça me fait
plaisir mais c'est juste du plaisir ça
me fait plaisir dans le service à
quelqu'un si je peux et et quand ça se
passe bien et
ça me fait aussi plaisir parfois de
voilà de mettre fin aux saloperies d'un
mec
voilà ça fait toujours plaisir mais dans
le sens du bon bar au moins pour un
moment qui fera plus rien
on
[Musique]
magath de protection des familles
bonjour à la brigade on enchaîne les
affaires
maltraitances de personnes âgées ayant
tu assistes
violence en milieu scolaire
ou encore disparition les cinq
enquêteurs traite plus de 450 dossiers
chaque année
dans la plupart des cas ce sont des
enfants qui sont impliqués et tout est
fait pour les mettre en confiance
chaque policier a reçu une formation
pour apprendre à recueillir cette parole
si fragile
des feux 36 ans tente un petit garçon de
six ans qui aurait subi des
attouchements sexuels
et comme chaque fois avec un mineur
l'audition est filmé
comment il a fait alors si tu me
n'explique pas je te passe moi
[Musique]
et ma voix
est ce que tu vaux autre chose
d'important médian
est ce que ça c'est produit d'autres
fois que cette fois là
dans le bureau d'à côté virginie
auditionne une nourrice accusé de
mauvais traitements sur un enfant de
deux ans donc voilà je lui ai mis une
claque et y avait des faits c'est bon
j'ai une foi une plaque puis c'est pas
là je parte à claques que je vous
faisais sur les fesses moi je vais vous
dire honnêtement ça mon point de vue
j'ai rien contre effet c'est bah oui
j'ai bien compris fessée mais le
problème c'est qu'il ya des fessées et
des claques ou de certaines personnes
n'ont pas eu non pas le roi c'est comme
ça je sais moi ma de nous était sévère
mais voilà c'est un souvenir voilà une
nounou c'est un souvenir quad enfants là
ça me dérange tous à la plus ça va plus
ça interrogeant en plus je suis sûr qu'à
des non dits que vous ne dites pas en
suis persuadé
en face stéphane entente une jeune fille
de 11 ans qui aurait été embrigadé dans
une secte
il appelle ça comment une église ils
appellent ça je suis une réunion une
réunion et quand le prêtre il parle
est-ce qu'il part en france est d'accord
tu comprends pas forcément ce qu'il dit
mais c'est du français
l'ong qui recule en l'homme pour prier
un billard français et moi j'aime pas
qu'on commence à travers
ces
thèmes pas être dans sa dans le seigneur
c'est à dire
pendant la réunion est-ce qu'il arrive
au prêtre doit d'autres gens de te
toucher toi de te toucher de m tu m'as
dit la main sur l'épaule ou toucher
n'importe quelle partie de ton corps d
un
jamais
est ce que quelqu'un t'a fait du mal
alors
c'est vrai ça
à laitages deux mondes se côtoient
les affaires de famille est au fond du
couloir les stups
normalement c'est de la côte il avait un
petit peu
fred et guillaume font l'inventaire de
leurs dernières saisies
et 210 de shit ils sont les témoins
privilégiés du travail de la brigade
logiquement on ne devraient pas
s'entendre c'est pas de matières qui
sont compatibles on a les mineurs et des
gamins qui jouent d'un côté nous
manipulent des produits stupéfiants tout
con il ya des forts caractères comme nos
états et à mon énergie ni mon cccc
lafitte d'état donc c'est elle on la
traite à part
vous aux stups est ce que vous pourriez
être à la brigade de protection de la
famille moins d'en haut non moi non je
pourrais pas je ne voudrais pas devoir
les les enfants comme ça j'adore les
gamins et non de voir les enfants qui
l'ont qui ont subi qu'ils ont subis et
d'avoir les auteurs sous la main je
pourrais pas et après c'est vrai qu'il
faut être costaud il ya des moments faut
avoir les reins solides
parce que c'est pas facile
parce que les victimes et les gamins et
les familles qui se déchire au code vous
dis un gamin comme ça et qu'après une
petite gamine qui vient qu'à trois
quatre ans et qui vient ici on en parle
après au café mais cette gamine la halle
a été victime de son père
il oblige à faire des fellations il ya
eu des attouchements et du viol après tu
renvoies puis l'appel la personne pareil
la pauvre gamine tout dit la subite ou
cinq et on espère que justement les
collègues vont réussir dans leurs
procédures accroché le gars pour que le
spectacle soit sous les verrous parce
que c'est
au rez-de-chaussée michael placent en
garde à vue un homme accusé de viol sur
mineure
ce père de famille aurait forcé sa fille
à lui faire une fellation quand elle
avait 11
mai d'accord à 9h15 ce alors vous êtes
arrivé au service pour les faits de viol
par ascendant
par ascendant vous êtes le père n'a
fallu voilà c'est pour ça vous attendiez
toute façon vous attendiez avec vous
convoque
michael a 48 heures pour établir la
vérité
ma collègue ou
deux jours pour comprendre ce qui s'est
réellement passé entre ce père et sa
fille il y a quatre ans
[Musique]
pour mickaël la fer s'engage bien on l'a
trop facile quel est celui qui sort de
huit
je peux me tromper mais souvent là
la première
premier contact avec avec la personne on
peut on voit si on est sur la bonne voie
ou pas là moi je pense qu on est plutôt
sur la bonne voie il sait il en a parlé
avec son avocat il sait pourquoi les
convoquer donc
tu fais le dissuader de rester
c'est votre journée s'annoncera j
très grosse journée qui s'annonce parce
que michael a prévu une garde à vue non
pour des faits assez important et nous
on l'est de jongle entre nos convoqué ce
qu'on a prévu et voilà
dix heures du matin l'audition démarre
savez vous ce que li na futur proche
je vais faire simple parce que voilà je
pense qu'il faut qu'on brasse 1 elle
vous reproche quoi une fois l'été chez
vous un soir vous étiez livre a été dans
la chambre vous êtes allé la voir hélas
elle déclare que vous lui avait imposé
une fellation voilà je sais que j'ai la
sq elle scanne le des noms comme le
dénonce je me fais rien d'autre j'ai
jamais fait ça ma fille
je jure ça vous savez ça c'est un
argument qui bouillent moi je sais que
ma fille ma propre fille brune
pour moi les manteaux tâche pas pourquoi
que je vais monter sans déjeuner
l'audition s'avère plus difficile que
prévu
je comprends qu'on n'attend pas en avant
non mais ça il faut pas vous réfugier
derrière je comprends pas pourquoi vous
savez moi j'ai réussi où les ultimes si
au bout de 15 ans disant qu'un parle
d'accord chaque victime à sa propre
prise par chaque victime à sa façon de
réagir rue donc ne me dit pas pour moi
c'est pas d'arguments je comprends pas
pourquoi j'en ai pas parlé d'accord mais
ça voilà que les faits non c'est non
mais je ne sais pas non je me sens très
bien
oui je vois mal oui bah oui
ok
[Musique]
deux heures d'interrogatoire est
toujours pas d'avs dans les affaires
d'inceste révélée tardivement sans trace
d'adr l'aveu reste une preuve
déterminants
[Musique]
cette fois ci
non c'est pas si facile que ça
le problème dans ce genre de dossier
c'est qu'on n'a aucun frein de matériel
c'est parole de l'un contre parole de
l'autre est
souvent la première audition
soit en effet dès la première audition
il se peut parfois des gens voilà où se
met à table ils disent vraiment tout ou
des fois maintenant ça marche pas la
première audition bas ça ça fonctionnera
peut-être à la 2d guara la troisième
mais il faut pas
faut pas faire preuve d'impatience tout
viendra qui viendra
non mais vraiment pas mais vraiment pas
hélas bah oui c'est complètement
complètement
droit je lui pose une question et je
suis quoi mais on va y arriver
virginie rigoles là mais les morts de
rire
et steve comment ça se passe par constat
je n'ai pas entendu la la matinée
tu lis mille-îles bientôt son mec ah non
non [ __ ] il s'est complètement fermé
comme une huître mais j'étais gentil n'a
rien du tout moi il dort tranquille un
fait l'arrière fait réveiller par contre
ils suent à grosses gouttes à venir
bon je sais que ses cheveux dont
elle se fout de ma gueule elle abuse
donc il va s'en sortir en fait ils
allaient la virginie
faut être humble souvenirs ait demandé
le retour n'est pas d'origine en tout
cas une chose est sûre c'est que je me
mette une piquette aubade ça comme ça
c'est génial taper des promesses en
matière à turin et l'as avait une
certitude dans la région
[Musique]
je suis pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est sûr et certain que tu as du sport
si la soupe on ne voit là c'est ce à
quoi on va parler d'une procédure assez
assez dur avec des faits assez
assez assez grave et puis hop on va le
midi ça y est dû autant un quart d'heure
de temps on va on va être dans la
légèreté du sport on va rigoler on va
voilà là les affaires mais il ya
quotidien et dans ce quotidien as qui
est pas facile à gérer des fois le sport
c'est important et à 14h par contre ben
on aura quand même
il faut avoir cette faculté de deux
heures de détente de retourner à 14h
dans le bain quoi
14 heures retour au commissariat et
nouvelle audition du père accusé de viol
virginie est venu en renfort
c'est que c'était dur un peu oui est ce
qu'il te disais des choses il disait
continu continu continu est ce que tu es
son sexe dans la bouche oui quel
mouvement il faisait tout obligé à faire
quoi avec son sexe dans la bouche
comment dire je ne sais pas avec quels
mots alors oui je me doutais pas le dire
est ce que tu faisais des eaux je
faisais ça et voulait je vous mime mais
je vous me mets moi j'ai pas honte à
vous voyez c'est bien entre parenthèses
du salut mec sa tête est mort de va et
vient voilà
est-ce que du lait qu'il est sorti son
sexe non oui
qui descendit dont celle de votre sexe
oui ou non non je suis pas jamais en
fait ma fille déjà
c'est ça la question je connais
donc est ce que votre fille vous à
suspense non je sais pas je me pose la
question
j'aime j'aime succès à paris et quand
vous êtes à trois grammes live mais plus
rien mais non je ressens à l'aja mais
j'ai ma relation watch d'accord un point
il faut croire bah oui parce que deux
buts depuis depuis ce matin vous mentez
le problème monsieur vous savez la lcf
et quel âge 15 ans gars va devenir une
save d'accord la vie sexuelle
alors voilà j'ai eu une mais moi je vous
parle en tant que femme s'étant
longtemps gagne parce que mr
et quand son mari ou quand son compagnon
dont elle serait super amoureux a
demandé une fellation parce que ça fait
partie des pratiques courantes forcément
un heiva quoi
elle voudra pas le faire ou à voudra pas
voilà parce que quoi il verra le sexe de
son père et la tête de son père qui
l'obligent qui nie continu-continu
bien si monsieur ça va être ça c'est ça
la réalité donc et baissera boursiers
wave haut mais ouais c'est à dire qu on
est paumé quand on dit pas la vérité
tout simplement je vous parlais comme un
enfant de 8 ans monsieur aphatie moment
autour du autour du pot vous êtes bien
là qu est ce que je vais dire est qu on
cherche on cherche nos réponses oui bah
on est paumé d'accord vous n'êtes pas
d'accord et que jeanne dire bah ouais
deux heures d'audition et le suspect ne
lâche toujours rien les deux enquêteurs
lui annonce alors qu'il va être
confronté à sa fille
j'ai même pas si elle vous en veut
quelque part je savais pas d'air on va
en lui demandera mais je ne sais même
pas elle veut pas qu'elle veut quoi elle
veut pas que vous aviez en prison saint
louis elle veut surtout que ses petits
frères puisera encore voir sont pas leur
papa et je veux pas pas d'un être que
paroles disent que ce qu'il a fait
passer une bêtise ouais
dans une demi heure là quand elle sera
là elle va avoir besoin d'entendre des
choses et moi j'ai pas vous faire de
cadeaux devant et ça que je préfère voir
un peu où faire prendre conscience tout
de suite avant qu'elle arrive parce que
nous assure que est en fonte avec sa
fille nous on fait tous les jours les
concours c'était pas évident tout à
l'heure alors ce que vous allez voir
votre fils à côté de vous vous allez
pouvoir regarder dans les andes et en
tuer une menteuse du bruit je ne te tais
tu me vois là
parce que là ça va se passer dans mon
bureau bon voilà dans les locaux de
police mais après il faut vivre avec
après oui non mais voyez rien
qu'est ce qu'on fait on collectivise à
l'audition on attend la confond tout
moment la chaîne tout de suite évoqué
voter
oui
- quoi je vais alléger ma fondation
donc je reconnais que ma fille m'a fait
une fellation
[Musique]
la présence de virginie deuxième
audition a été déterminante
déterminante oui ce serait mentir de
dire le contraire
déterminante
on line ben oui puisque on va dire oui
puisque le monsieur
il est venu après aux aveux ça l'a
certainement peut-être troublé aussi le
monsieur qu'une femme même vienne
interviennent parle de sexualité dans
nous avec ses mots à lui ça l'a
peut-être un peu surprise comme un
enfant on va essayer parler avec ses
mots et ben agresseur sexuel on va lui
parler avec ces mots quoi
moi je pense que j'ai le souci un des
soucis c'est que j'ai encore du mal
peut-être mais tarde à la hauteur des
gens et leur vocabulaire j'essaie de
faire des phrases
voilà parce que bon c'est normal naturel
mais non des fois il faut parler la
france quoi et vous ça vous gêne pas
utilisé ces mots là ça gêne pas dans ce
bureau quand il est fermé dans ce
contexte là après j'aimerais pas que ma
famille va entendre parler comme ça
c'est clair je ne parle pas comme ça
faut le savoir quand même je parle comme
ça quand addition c'est bon
c'est maintenant l'heure du face à face
entre le père et sa fille de 15 ans qui
arrive avec son avocate
[Musique]
ok là ça y est c'est fait on a fait le
travail on a travaillé d'accord mon
collègue toute la matinée on appris
d'accord ok là on pose je fais tout ce
que tu as eu le coeur avec tes mots
d'accord
on y va et forte
la confrontation une épreuve pour la
victime mais une nécessité pour les
enquêteurs qui veulent lever 1 derniers
doutes sur le déroulement des faits
aujourd'hui la danse bureau ce qui se
passe dans le bureau reste dans le
bureau on règle le problème après la
justice à prendre le relais ok d'accord
donc
sur les faits j'étais chez mon père je
vais chez lui l'avait vu il avait
tellement bu que je suis parti dans la
chambre il m'a appelé et obligé de venir
le père reconnaît les faits dénoncés par
sa fille à l'exception d'une chose il
prétend que c'est elle qui a
volontairement sorti son sexe de son
temps à autre chose ou non il ya un
point quand vous n'êtes pas d'accord au
niveau du sexe
[Musique]
d'accord mais à votre demande
augmente et on m'a tendu des 41 oui
j'espère tu as bien trappe et moi m'a
jamais demandé quoi que tu peux te
laisse pas d'accord t'es même pas photo
moi je ne parle pas bien ce qu'est ce
que tu as fait d'accord
pourquoi et gaza ce soit justement vous
n'êtes pas d'accord
mega man
show qu'il a reconnu déjà ce qui s'est
passé que nous manque juste ce petit
détail dans mon verre comme est fatale
je ne sais pas justement je suis
d'accord avec toi on est d'accord pour
que les prochains si toi qu'il reconnaît
pas c'est toi qui m'as fait c'est pas
moi
[Musique]
je tombe pas toute entente or tu vois
vous avez changé ton d'accord parce que
les tigres est pas la maison un dragon
de police aurait dû parler différemment
les ja oui comme dimanche raymond vall
et baisser d'un pont parce que ça je
n'apprécie pas du tout on va pas
inverser les rôles on va pas inverser
les rôles je vous le dis d'accord
vous êtes en face de votre fille votre
fille à 14-15 ans voilà elle s'exprime
elle pleure écrit je vous cache pas que
ça je la laissais faire d'accord par
contre vous
piano man est ce que c'est vous qui lui
demander de sortir votre sexe
on est d'accord donc on est d'accord
c'est lui qui même visuel père voilà
vous connaissez vous les faits qui lui
sont reprochés
oui
avez-vous jeu ajouté
je trouve de 120 kwh
pendant quatre ans sophie à porter
seules le poids de ce viol sa mère ne
l'a jamais crue alors virginie a tenu à
la faire venir elle aussi pour qu'elle
entende la vérité
tu
as
vraiment pour un peu sale m'en vouloir
mais non mais je vais pas tenter alors
elle a été super courageux vraiment
sachiez qu'il a reconnu les faits tout
ce qu'a dit votre fille est ce que ce
qu'il faut là mais j'ai pas de conseils
donnés je me permettrai surtout pas
c'est à fond soutenir votre fille quoi
dans la démarche loyer elle a été le
faire allez on arrivé là juste jusque là
aujourd'hui mais il est arrivé tout seul
quoi quatre ans
je te remercie tu as été très courageuse
en une bonne soirée
[Musique]
sophie va pouvoir enfin quitté le foyer
où elle était placée est retournée vivre
chez sa mère son père passe sa dernière
nuit en garde à vue demain il sera fixé
sur son sort
après une journée comme ça qu'est ce que
vous aimez dans dans tout ce qu'on voit
dans tout ce que voir la misère du monde
comme savoir les pires facettes de
l'être humain voir des gamins amoché
voir des gamins violet voilà j'en sais
strictement rien
peut-être qu'à ce mot aussi aura
peut-être qu'au moment où ils sont dans
mon bureau je suis peut-être ou avec les
collègues on est peut-être les seules
personnes qui peuvent les aider à un
moment t on qu'on s'y prendrait
peut-être utile la police est utile à ce
moment là bas après
on passe autour d'eux elle passe à autre
chose
[Musique]
comme tous les soirs michael rentre chez
lui à la campagne retrouver ses trois
enfants
j'ai à peu près à les 20 minutes 20 25
minutes de route entre le bureau et la
maison pour essayer de trouver le sas
hop je rentre dans le sas
je me change dans l'amour costumes
d'enquêteurs et j'arrive à la maison et
voilà
on n'en parle pas on parle plus je
revais plutôt mon costume de papa et
puis voilà mais en effet c'est vraiment
un grand écart on va dire
[Musique]
ce serait mentir de dire que je pense
pas la relation entre mes enfants ils
enfants que je reçois parce que souvent
à faire dès qu'on parle pas des
comparaisons mais retient même âge qu'un
même coiffure tient même pull oui on
fait des relations après j'essaie je
fais je fais en sorte de ne pas faire
l'amalgamé entre mes enfants et les
autres entre ma vie familiale était ma
vie professionnelle
sont des mots ce sont des mots
c'est bien de le dire après il faut
essayer de le faire et de noix il y
arriver c'est encore autre chose
pourquoi
le lendemain matin au palais de justice
de caen les trois enquêteurs présentent
le père incestueux au procureur la
justice prend la relève
quasi judiciaire vierge elle va pas bien
aux juniors
ils avaient vu en confrontation
[Musique]
c'est bon pour elle
donc l'issue de deux enquêtes parce que
je veux vous voir imposer cette
interdiction absolue entrer en contact
avec inès ça veut dire ne pas l'avoir ne
pas l'appeler une bonne nouvelle aucun
contact de quelques la turquie soit
le procureur décide de le poursuivre
pour agression sexuelle sur mineur de
moins de 15 ans avec une circonstance
aggravante les faits ont été commis sur
sa propre fille
deux mois plus tard le père sera
condamné à quatre ans de prison dont
trois avec sursis et obligation de soins
qu'a fait hier
alors les filles de retour au
commissariat pause café dans le bureau
des stups
ont baissé lundi à la fin il faut que
j'ai pas vu que j'avais pas vu le film
et
[Musique]
ça sonne chez toi ni ni
ok
je suis pour rien à voir avec ton équipe
il y aura moins qu'il a dit karim toi tu
me tires animaux semblent en fait vous
la tyranniser quoi pas moi cela seul
chef fred même étant la seule elle
arrive à renverser la situation c'est
vrai des stéphane de les voir il ya
toujours une façade au rire parce que
ben voilà on est aimé chacun voilà on
reste des êtres humains et tous les
journaleux difficulté aussi profond
côtoie aussi la misère du monde c'est
une forme de soupape pour pour les
libérer quoi bafoue pas font pas franc
parler il faut qu'on en parle il faut
qu'on rigole justement faut qu'on expose
faux-pas corps est dans la misère quelle
que soit la difficulté
s'il ya une bonne une bonne ambiance
dans les équipes vous pouvez faire
n'importe quoi
familles des victimes attention à ce que
tu dis non non tous les garçons c'est
mon équilibre
festina
[Musique]
la pause est de courte durée
dans le couloir camille 12 ans est au
coeur d'un conflit entre ses deux
parents sa mère est venue déposer une
plainte contre son mari pour menaces de
mort
c'était la première fois qu'il eut
menacé de mort non et mal il m'a déjà
dit une fois que cg doman guiboles là il
y aura du centre
[Musique]
je vous demandais si vous voulez bien de
patienter dans le couloir je vais
entendre votre fille ça marche mirta sur
l'angle
je vais pas tomber tes longtemps j'ai
besoin de savoir quelle est l'ambiance à
la maison comment ça se passe depuis
combien de temps ça se passe et ce que
tu en penses toi jeu que ce soit toi qui
parles cette eau
[Musique]
est ce que tu as déjà vu des violences
physiques à la maison violence physique
on veut dire on se tape on se cogne on
se bouscule on se tire les cheveux on se
met des gifles on se fait des trucs
comme ça enfin peu importe est ce que tu
as déjà vu ça à la maison non
ils s'engueulent miss top quoi c'est ça
en gros
qu'est ce que tu as entendu comme un
futur
à la foulée justement on est là pour un
peu comprendre ok stéphane il a tout
entendu taquet voir aujourd'hui willows
inn à midi exactement ce que tu entends
c'est c'est important quand
ta maman elle parle de une fois
notamment ai dit que c'est arrivé
plusieurs fois qu'elle se fasse menacé
et qu'une fois tu étais là et notamment
une des dernières fois il lui dit ce
n'est même pas un cru que tu as un
garage habite là [ __ ] la négresse
n'est pas tombé ici [ __ ] put si tu
peux acheter gorge il a fait le signe de
l'égorgement avec ses doigts comme ça un
an les plaçant sous sa gorge est ce que
c'est le 100e rappelle quelque chose
[Musique]
maman elle a parlé de d'armes d'armes à
la maison est ce que tu en as déjà vu
[Musique]
confiance d'accord avec
les
appétits
ministre la plainte
derrière cette question toi tu veux quoi
toi qui m'a insulté notamment substrat
l'intérieur
d'accord
j'ai pas ça pour te faire pleurer
justement je vais faire pour avoir ton
sentiment c'est important pour qu'on
puisse essayer de trouver une solution
qu'est ce tu penses toi te papa
qu'est ce que tu souhaites de nous
sont peu trop enclavé
quelques fans
on ne promet pas on va tout faire 1
je remercie au passage au pouvoir en
irak au pont
[Musique]
elle parlera
et 1,9 m la cabine on est sur des
menaces de mort la gamine allait
affecter est complètement nous est
complètement stressée elle aime son père
peu pus d'allaiter toujours quoi l'aller
elle se retrouve mêlé à une histoire de
grand enjeu je pense qu'on peut
considérer que les enfants sont victimes
même s'il a en effet on n'a pas de trace
de coup n'a pas voilà mais là c'est
vraiment des violences qu'elle qu'elle
prend en voilà en pleine tête et voilà
mais il ya des armes quoi donc hors de
question qu'on laisse cette famille avec
cette tension et des armes à domicile
quoi ça c'est sûr et certain on y va
c'est parti les enquêteurs décident de
perquisitionner l'appartement avec
l'accord de la mère de kani
y a pas de chien
c'est bon pour moi sofia au fond du
couloir la chambre du père fermée à clé
[Musique]
je comprends un petit peu plus parce
qu'on sait pas pour vous embêter de
couacs l'a fait avec les armes à la
maison sachant quotas c'est que vous
êtes venu et tous assis s'il s'en
portent que ce soit
les enquêteurs découvrent un revolver 9
mm des centaines de cartouches ce
calibre 12 plusieurs carabines deux
fusils des lunettes de visée et des
boîtes remplies de couteau
qu'est-ce que tu ressembles
[Musique]
dans l'entrée michael découvre un cagibi
lui aussi fermé à clé
wenger bonne pioche
ces fréquences donc
si on tombe sur des férus de chair fouet
bon là il y en a beaucoup rien n'a
beaucoup vrai qu'on est dans une une
région où avec le le débarquement
seconde guerre mondiale les fautes vous
pouvez tomber sur des collectionneurs
d'armes de guerre qui ça qu'ils sont
souvent neutraliser mon travail mais là
là où l on trouve sur 10 on peut parler
de petit arsenal là quand même
vous saviez parents qui avaient tout ça
tu peux pas laisser pas d'accord je
l'appelle dès que je rentre premier truc
que je fais mes collègues ce que mes
armes je l'appelle et le moins bon sur 6
le 17 pour on vous l'a déjà dit mais le
17 et si vous voyez vraiment que la
situation est vraiment temps du bon
voila vous prenez plus de 3 à faire chez
une voisine si vous êtes la famille mais
en tout cas fait le disent être en
priorité d'accord façon ça y est la
procédure est lancée et
d'accord
les policiers n'ont pas d'autre choix
ils doivent laisser camier sa mère seule
ce soir
pour les sécuriser ils emportent des
armes au commissariat
une fois qu'on est parti on ferme la
porte et puis voilà quoi on s est maman
avec avec sa fille donc ouais on ferme
la porte tous à notre dossier la preuve
l'attitude et voilà je repasse tutelle
de siècle ça s'est passé il ya une heure
stéphane appelle le mari pour le
convoquer il en profite pour le mettre
en garde
elle a fait une perquisition à votre
domicile par contre ce soir c'est pas le
bordel et les jours suivants non plus
d'accord c'est à dire que je veux pas de
bagarre je veux pas d'engueulades
toute façon s'il ya quelque chose comme
ça il ya une intervention de police et
ça se passera mal horatio
l'homme va devoir venir s'expliquer au
commissariat sur les menaces de mort et
justifiée avec un permis chacune des
armes saisies à son domicile
[Musique]
virginie elle se prépare entendre louise
quatre ans elle accuse son demi frère de
13 ans de lui avoir fait des
attouchements sexuels
sais tu pourquoi tu es venu me voir
ouais qu'est ce qui t'a fait
[Musique]
je veux dire est qu à poupet alors vas-y
il a fait ça d'accord
ok et ça s'est passé où
et quand il a touché là est ce que tu as
eu mal
non
ex qui l'a fait autre chose
est-ce qui t a touché quelque part
d'autre sur ton corps non
vas-y prend avec ses vrais cv lien elle
est belle je trouve pas
non bah ouais mais bon la vague celle là
as tu vu le pays de thongue confrères
non d'accord et il a touché plusieurs
fois ici ou qu'une fois
d'accord il a fait qu'un seul jour
où il a fait plusieurs jours
d'accord
bah ouais j'ai fait parce que toi aussi
tu parle tellement bien que je suis
obligé d'aller vite
comment tu appelles par où tu fais pipi
comment tu appelles à part où tu fais
pitié
et appelle ça comment toi
tu appelles ça les fait d'accord
lundi soir pour ton calme salon à
huawei que la celle ci elle est jolie et
on t'a vu un beau chapeau rose qui
brillent comme ses boucles d'oreilles
voilà
et quand on la touche et effet ce qu'est
ce qu'il a dit
bien d'accord et est ce que quelqu'un
d'autre a touché les fesses
d'accord on arrête là 1 parce que ça
fait beaucoup déjà là
où est inquiète j'ai pas oublié alors il
ya citron orange parce que c'est les
autres enfants ont déjà pris tous les
autres citron ça va aller
tu attends avec mamie
après louise c'est au tour de son frère
raphaël d'être entendu virginie veut
s'assurer qu'il n'a pas lui aussi été
victime
sais tu ce qui lui a fait exactement
la sainte eulalie
donc moi selon ce qu'on m'a dit il
aurait touché le sexe de ta petite soeur
c'est ça est ce que toi il t'a déjà
touché le sexe zizi
est-ce que tu l'as vu déjà faire ça à
quelqu'un d'autre
par exemple sur l'ordinateur est ce qui
va sur des choses bizarres comme des
films avec des hommes ou des femmes tout
nu nantes a jamais vu ça toi qui vas sur
ordinateur avec lui d'accord qu'est ce
qu'on pense de cette histoire
honnêtement
pour nous tous d'accord
c'est pas ça te
salaire quand même tracasser ça te rend
moins je vois bien question pensent à
tord en tri 7e rang c'est justement en
colère bah oui tout ce que j'aimerais
bien voir briller d'accord pourquoi tu
voudrais le voir explique moi ta loi ici
justement la loi tout dire
justement font que je sache que tu
penses pouvoir un petit peu et d'être
dans ce dossier qui est compliqué vu que
ça entre frères et soeurs ans
parce que je me laisse pjak est d'accord
et tulle aime bien
arte a peur de quoi là
ne pas le revoir d'accord mais je vais
le noter d'accord c'est important que tu
me dis tout ça si je comprends c'est ton
frère
puis c'est compliqué je suppose de dire
ça à papa et maman non bah oui et caché
bon compte alors oui
je peux pas de promettre je peux faire
c'est à dire tu peux le revoir mais faut
pour l'instant le temps qu'on comprenne
ce qui s'est passé un d'accord ça va
être lent quête qui va déterminer et ben
faut qu'ils aient tout le temps
quelqu'un qui vous surveille et puis
même si un adulte que je veux juillet
par les rouges d'une bêtise mais dans le
jardin et qui a un adulte ok j'ai pas
t'embêter plus longtemps si je vois que
c'est dur là si tu as quelque chose à me
dire où quelque chose a sur le coeur
c'est le moment ou jamais de me dire
tiens à les lire ok
je corrige mes fautes sadorge papillon
toi aussi tu en fais des fautes des fois
on dicte et oui
parfait
je te remercie en tout cas je sais que
c'était dur pour toi j'ai de faire
signer j'imprime ça t'a fait du bien
quand même un petit peu voiture retrouvé
un peu le sourire déjà abbas est mieux
là à les jeunes hommes une signature
s'il vous plaît un autographe
comme star de hockey
ou pas mal encore in
super merci
[Applaudissements]
ces bonnes âmes
[Musique]
la petite est maintient les faits par
contre le petit frère biens affectés ce
qu'ils voient lui sait qui il peut plus
voir son grand frère quand est vraiment
d'un conflit je n'ai entendu le way
n'ont rien lui il est pas victime quoi
là que la petite qui là vous êtes sûr
qu'elle est victime la main sur nous on
n'est jamais sûr n'en parle d'un enfant
c'est la parole des frères des soeurs et
ses craintes et jamais sur les trois
quarts du temps c'est du viol intra
familiales ou en tout cas avec des
proches c'est sur le long terme et à les
gentils talent et les enfants qui ne te
dise pas ça dès la première fois mais
c'est le cas où vraiment est sûre on a
du biscuit nous c'est quand tu as des
des traces gynécologique ou des témoins
oculaires la plupart du temps bonjour
chers il j'ai ça à dire points et après
tu joues avec c'est dur d'entendre mes
enfants ben la petite là elle était
tellement tellement gay être tellement
mignonne tellement jovial qu'à la limite
c'est un jeu là vraiment c'était un jeu
est tout à l'heure parce que ça se
passait bien plusieurs ses boucles
d'oreilles c'était vraiment s qui était
plus du plus dur c'est son frère son
frère qu'il n'est pas victime est à la
fois il s'est mis à pleurer parce qu'il
est très attaché à l'auteur qui est son
grand frère et sa ouais là on commence à
avoir la boule au ventre et on cible on
sent que ça va pas et on le fait parler
et puis il nous dit ce qui peut pas dire
à ses parents parce que nous on est
neutres on est policier et on met dib et
toi tu peux tout nous dire et là là ça
commence à la limite c'est pas lui qui
est victime et c'est lui qui est le plus
touchant dans tout ça quoi donc voilà ça
c'est dur
une semaine plus tard leur demi-frère a
reconnu les faits plus grave encore il a
avoué s'être livré à des attouchements
sur sa petite soeur à cinq reprises
l' enquête est toujours en cours
[Musique]
le lendemain michael en temps le
propriétaire de l'arsenal saisi la
veille
à peine arrivé il est prise en charge
par la police scientifique
comme tous les suspects qu'ils arrivent
ici il est fiché
[Musique]
c'est la première fois qu'il a affaire à
la police
je trouve ça assez stressant on ait eu
l'image ou comme à nanterre on dire on
prend encore on avait un truc genre mais
l'arrivée à séoul enfin non des
engueulades de coupe c'est tout
rien d'autre de simples engueulades mais
avec soupçon de menaces de mort un délit
passible d'une peine pouvant aller
jusqu'à trois ans de prison
virginie a l'habitude de ces conflits
entre conjoints on joue un rôle de
policier au niveau justice qui est à la
fois cet enjeu social et puis conseiller
conjugal on fait tous là on va faire
tout ça va être un pack là assis vous
monsieur
donc on y va dans ses affaires sans
preuve c'est la parole de l'un contre la
parole de l'autre
on a été chez vous on découvre tout ça
et vous allez me dire ce qu'il en est et
on va commencer bas sur la base c'est à
dire les menaces
est malade je veux à bacalan mais non
mais c'est normal que vous attendez vous
êtes convoqué à la police on a trouvé
des armes et tout chaussures way et j'en
veux provoquer quelques uns deux ans que
je connais mieux de la chasse
mon père est chasseur vous allez pas
pouvoir me voir moi tour nous paie
maintenant ce moment là jamais monsieur
avec une arme des injures oui ça je le
sais pas moi-même sommes un peu dans un
jeu
ok on y va alors l'avez vous insultez
deux garages habite
je me prive encore pas que j'oublie le
carreau [ __ ] alors oui car elle
sortait je vous dire la suite pour quoi
que je dise oh ah oui car elle sortait
avec un quoi je ne tenais pas à priori
le chopper ambages de notre père notre
aval elle m'a dit qu'elle s'est mariée
avec moi pour les régler
l'insulté vous des propos racistes
supposions et par une négresse et tout
ça oui
voyez en tout cas je comprends pas c'est
quand vous l'avez connu e après
google je suis fait avoir c'est tout
d'accord moi je vous dis je le mets je
vous le dis je les aimais ce qu'il faut
penser aux enfants aussi l'api ne l'a
pas demandé allez ça
ah bah non non je ne fais pas le jeu
mais n'ont même pas vu non plus dans
cette ambiance un sabot c'est là
moi ce que je veux c'est le calme moi
oui vos sentiments à je sais pas moi ça
me regarde pas je ne fume à la péninsule
tard on est d'accord h note
vous pouvez le remarquer
alors on va prendre à part c'est
compliqué ce que nous c'est pas notre
spécialité dont +1 les armes mais une
virginie et mickaël doivent maintenant
vérifier que chacune de ces armes et
bien déclarée donc concernant consultant
jean marie loury ce que tu as déjà
convaincu on voit les déclarer
et le fusil de chasse baïkal calibre 12
jours voilà sur lé bon il déclaré dans
ces deux là sont ces deux là sont bonnes
les fusils sont en règle seuls deux
révolvers et une carabine n'ont pas
d'existence légale c'est pas net les
arts ces palettes
vous savez très bien que les angles
c'est assez sensible et là c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve chez vous bon des âmes
qui sont tantôt déclaré donc ça c'est
bien tantôt elles ne sont pas des carrés
de là c'est un peu moins bien on va dire
que ce trou au niveau de la legislation
êtes un peu léger voire un peu
négligents non non je ne pense pas mais
vous savez lorsqu'on a des armes comme
ça cette fois c'est un peu sensible et
dans s'intéresse aussi à la législation
pour être au moins dans les clous quoi
bon le fait dit il
la loi contraint des enquêteurs à lui
restituer les armes en règle chez moi je
suis pas pris pour un bruyant son
soulagement
mais s'est soulagé de repartir avec
césar mais vous vous êtes soulagés qui
repartait
non j'ai pas vous dire de quoi soulager
nom
mais qui n'a qu'une parole j'espère
moi oui
bon ça regarde en face vous avez des
mois pour régulariser jusqu'à
finalement faute de preuves l'homme
repart libre avec une partie de sa
collection
[Musique]
monsieur d'arbres je pense que dans ce
conflit là chacun vraiment sa part de
responsabilité on aurait plutôt tendance
à dire que c'est à dire qu'il est
victime de sa fin mais on va dire qu'il
est peut-être un peu moins en hauteur
mais heureusement qu'on
on réussit et qu'on évolue dans notre
enquête sinon si on part bille en tête
avec en se disant tiens lui en effet il
est auteur et
on serait là qu'à charge c'est pas notre
travail c'est pas notre travail
[Musique]
laurent est le nouveau commandant du
groupe il arrive tout droit de la
brigade financière
il a quitté les chiffres pour les
secrets de famille
j'ai l'impression de ne pas savoir grand
chose quoi bon le problème c'est que je
suis entouré par des gens qui sont
tellement professionnels qui savent
tellement de choses que moi j'ai
l'impression d'arriver d'être
complètement néophytes quoi aborder un
enfant
c'est pas simple quoi en plus le truc
c'est que moi j'ai été confronté
pratiquement je sais plus si c'est la
première ou la deuxième audition où une
petite fille a complètement refusé de
rentrer dans le bureau quoi donc je me
suis dit waouh ça commence plutôt mal je
me suis dit là il ya quelque chose je me
suis rendu compte que c'était pas simple
et puis j'étais attendu dans cette
brigade je sais que c'est un challenge
pour moi d'être à la hauteur de leurs
attentes aussi ils attendent de moi que
je me sens que je me positionne aussi en
qualité de responsable de chef moi je me
sens quand même investi quoi ii d'une
mission la
même si ça se fait naturellement mais
moi je pense que je me mets quand même
une barras et autres
à peine arrivé au commissariat
laurent doit déjà partir en mission avec
stéphane trois enfants en bas âge
vivraient dans des conditions d'hygiène
catastrophiques
pouvez vous lancer la police
vous n'avez pas la clé
on vous l'appelez voulait titre que la
police est là qu on veut l'avoir
immédiatement
et puis vous vous tenez au courant
j'attends derrière la poste
[Musique]
bon ok on attend
comment se fait-il que vous êtes enfermé
comme ça
comme si vous avez besoin de sortir car
nous contenter
s'arrêtant le siège comme anthony
sarghat des mineurs
tout de suite les policiers sont saisis
par une odeur d'excréments
les poubelles s'accumulent depuis des
mois dans toutes les pièces
[Musique]
dans la chambre des enfants les matelas
sont imprégnées du rin
c'est dégueulasse par terre c'est
dégueulasse au mur c'est dégueulasse
partout
oui monsieur
d'accord quand il est tout seul c'est
lui qui décide s'il veut garder ma fille
c'est dans cet état depuis combien de
temps on a cumulé l'absence de ménager
ou cette femme de ménage
vous êtes quoi
assistante en crèche
reposant même que vous ayez conscience
qu'on est là aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya
une histoire de délaissement mineurs
même si les enfants sont pas là comme
vous dites ça n'a rien à voir des snow
mineurs c'est ne pas s'occuper
correctement ses enfants point barre
donc là on peut pas dire que vous
occuper correctement de vos enfants si
je croise à nous dire non au contraire
laurent décide de convoquer le couple au
commissariat dès l'après midi
moi je vais pas vous faire la morale de
la journée 1 voilà donc les huit ans au
lieu d'attendre dans la chambre à vous
nettoyer tous les deux
vers les entendre sur procès verbal au
travail et non
non j'en ai pas dakar at war qui n'ont
plus façon honnête comme ça avec un peu
vers le sud et l'est qui nous envoient
chaque fois je sais pas
booba paul martin vous avez paris
n'aurait pas un tee shirt vous trouver
un truc vous fait pas avec votre
couverture ce qu'on est pas chez moi la
liste
à tout à l'heure c'est dans une extrême
la fava d'arriver dans des situations
comme ça on en fait des perquisitions
des constatations chez les gens où on
arrive on s'assiéra est pas non plus
mais c'est pas à ce point là
là faut venir avec des gants courant si
on cherche quelque chose en particulier
on n'a pas le choix puis à la limite ce
n'est une charlotte sur la tête une
combinaison pour pas se laisser
on sait pas c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment dans un état
demander si on peut pas choper autre
chose
donc là quand on imagine les petits qui
vivent là dedans à longueur de journée
nuit
ça fait quand même un peu corps
[Musique]
enfin je tiens au courant pour
accompagner
[Musique]
d'autre part les gars at war
bézy entré ses 16 heures le couple
arrive ils sont suspectés de
délaissement de mineur et risque de
perdre provisoirement la garde de leurs
trois enfants comment vous expliquez ça
roule état d'insalubrité laconique été
constatée chez
paypal dont on l'expliqué maintenant je
veux dire pourquoi pourquoi en pourquoi
pourquoi on en arrive à ce point
cette accusation
[Musique]
à mon avis c'était pub bien au delà de
un mois mais moi pendant pendant un mois
on est en négligeant j'arrive pas à si
on éducatrice avait clairement
qu'elle a constaté quoi
[Musique]
lors de cette audition laurent découvre
que la mer est suivi par des
travailleurs sociaux depuis quatre ans
le couple est séparé le père sans emploi
vit toujours chez son ex femme et les
enfants sont livrés à eux mêmes
quels sont les gens qu'il a ça dans
l'appartement un chien chier partout
quoi dire ils sont quand même pas si
nombreux que ça quand ils ne semblent
pas je vais faire
et pourquoi vous l'avez pas fait jusque
là parce que j'ai la mauvaise habitude
de dire toujours dans sa
[Musique]
négligence des parents manque de suivi
des éducateurs la justice a tranché en
donnant une dernière chance au couple il
échappe au placement de leurs trois
enfants à condition qu'ils remettent
leur appartement en état et se soumettre
à un suivi plus renforcée des services
sociaux
si tu veux manger du pâté de lait bio
tradition oblige un vendredi par mois la
brigade organise un dîner à des tarés
un dîner qu'ils partagent bien sûr avec
les stups
[Musique]
ce couloir où se croise habituellement
victime est accusé se transforme en
salle des fêtes
[Musique]
je t'ai fait tu viens nous aider ou vous
comme d'hab tu arrives et tout sera prêt
et virginie vous fait quoi exactement
les hommes travaillez vous
je délègue et je dirige non non non on
fait tous ensemble
non mais faut aider démotiver les petits
gars
c'est stéphane ne voyez fut passe à la
maison tu peux faire des plus gros
morceau stéphane les matons qui en fait
on a prévu encore personne
[Musique]
le dîner est prêt même si l étage
certains travaillent ton corps
c'était prévu notre basculer
[Musique]
bah oui parce que tu es noir
écoute les mineurs et les stups c'est un
drôle de mariage non c'est complètement
fou
c'est une album ça s'accorde même pas
ceci dit vous verrez rarement les
mineurs travaillaient à 23 heures la
différence on n'écrit pas papa avec 3 p
à part tout le sang
ce matin un couple attend cellules de
garde à vue le mari et la femme sont
soupçonnés de maltraitance sur leur bébé
de deux mois qui a trois fractures au
crâne
c'est un dossier voilà qui est qui est
important et nous tous les témoignages
sont sont utiles à l'anc est donc je
pense qu'il serait intéressant de
les parents parlent d'une chute
accidentelle
le corps médical suspecte des violences
volontaires
pour l'instant il a que nous quoi même
s'il a deux parents mais les deux
parents sont suspect va pour l'instant
avec la police pour avoir la vérité il a
personne d'autre et puis si ses parents
veut récupérer l'enfant et bagnac toki
la peau on va essayer déterminer ce qui
s'est passé
[Musique]
sur le plan médical le bébé semble sorti
d'affaires il a été placé en coupe aux
nières mais pourra-t-il retourner sans
danger chez ses parents
les enquêteurs cherchent des réponses
auprès du père et de la mère
que s'est il
passé
qui a justifié l'hospitalisation
du v12 écoute vaches pour ma fille dans
les bras
la fissure dans votre ado je file
à gauche
regarde box fruité que la fin du bit
s'endort et moi je m'endors gens que je
connais vidéo
en fait j'écris en même temps par
l'acteur jonah latex avec son air de
quoi de profondeur soit en voiture
n'importe quoi quand on se doit sur
laquelle j'étais dans ce cadre elle a
voulu retrouver par terre voilà je
comprends on mais vous êtes en tailleur
rien vous endormez ce à toutes les
mamans que pomper tout je suis maman y'a
pas de soucis par contre y'a un truc
vous réveillant en sursaut mais ça je
peux vous le prouver par a plus b
vous savez un bébé dans les bras votre
reflex c'est pas de faire ça votre
reflex me faire ça parce
qu'inconsciemment vu que vous dites
piqué du nez vous n'êtes pas dormi
pendant trois heures voilà des pics et
des noms je croyais d'accord si tu
n'arrives la suite à une machine vilains
braga ce qui m'arrive madame je vous dis
franchement j'espère ça vous arrivera
pas et pense pas vous expliquer ce que
ça mon bébé je dois la check list et je
peux vous dire
moi
pour vous cette impression est arrivé
moi ce type a dont le son
de ma femme dit qu'est ce que le made in
apple a pas menti l'egypte est ce qui se
passe exact d'en faire une chose
pareille sur ma petite fille sur sa
petite fille
c'est pas possible ça ni vous ni votre
femme vous n'avez frappé facile ou ne
frappe pas mon prix philippe hersant
peuvent le phare fait sur mon fils et
mon sens cette fois c'est toute chose
c'est très bien oui mais votre santé
votre foi va falloir le récupérer pour
l'instant assez d'accord
je comprends que c'est votre sens je
comprends que ça vous emmerde je
comprends que ça vous fait chier tout ça
pas voir ça mais
je finis à la peine deux mois et vous
est déjà arrivé ici je comprends que ça
vous emmerde maintenant il ya un moment
donné monsieur il faut comprendre c'est
qu'on est la vérité pour l'instant cela
pour l'instant elle est placée à la
pouponnière et on a des médecins qui
disent elles à trois fractures elle en a
pas qu'une seule et elle a un seul
impact on arrivé sain à l'expliquer ce
qui est sûr c'est que l'on fait pas
trois fractures à un moment au niveau du
crâne comme ça juste avec une chute pack
recevoir comme de l'explication mais ce
match psg om est l'explication ne
correspond pas
malgré ces interrogatoires
le mari et la femme livre exactement la
même version des faits pour eux il
s'agit d'un accident et en aucun cas de
violences volontaires
vous mangez ce midi repas ce que faisait
peser à un peu vous grignotez un truc
entre chaque audition les parents sont
placés chacun dans une cellule ils ne
doivent avoir aucun contact toute la
durée de la garde à vue
elle est carrément céda faut des
médecins les médecins disent que des
conneries mais c'est des menteurs tout
lui c'est pareil
lui c'est pareil sauf qu'il est prêt à
tout prendre sur le dos
pourvu que sa femme s'en sortent et son
enfant s'en sortent pas de sens et puis
elle va pendant des mois en danger d'y
aller voilà quoi et bien si c'était la
vérité poney jeux ça arrive souvent dans
votre métier de douter comme ça ah bah
oui parce que ouais bien sûr qu'on a un
doute parce que nous on nettoie là on
les connaît pas ces gens là on n'est pas
forcément là pour les enfants c'est un
peu du tout même s'il pense ça mais nous
ça nous fait pas plaisir de mettre des
gens en prison s'ils ont rien fait c'est
pas notre but du tout donc forcément que
on est à la recherche de la vérité donc
toutes les hypothèses sont bonnes à
prendre et ouais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas voilà on est sûrs dans le
pourquoi pas
dans le doute naldo toujours tireur
toujours
virginie veut entendre à nouveau le
médecin expert qui a vu l'enfant elle
cherche à savoir si les déclarations de
la mère peuvent expliquer les trois
fractures du bébé cette version est ce
que ça pourrait causer
déçu que vous avez constaté
actuellement de mes projets compris
les trois fractures restent inexpliquées
fini décide alors d'emmener la mère du
bébé à son domicile
avec français d'affaires elle veut lui
faire répéter les gestes qu'elle évoque
dans son audition mais cette fois dans
sa chambre
je crois que des comme ça va ça c'est
important ça comme ça
vous prenez comme chez vous faisait
découvrir et
essayer m avec comme pour vous souvenir
avec l'intensité c'est ça je voudrais
voir leur mariage mais je vais essayer
de kikinda ce cas là mais ses petits
bras croisés on était comme ça quoi
évoquant joueur doit en fait j'ai eu un
réflexe sa fille
sarah binet les parties et quand je vais
retrouver ma gamine a été par terre a
bougé ce qui m'arrive et je me suis levé
j'ai fait ça je suivais mon mari qu'on a
entendu un élu en courant demandé ce qui
se passait je sors faut ramasser maquis
qui lit j'ai tout et j'ai tu es jeune et
oui je suis partie un tremblement et on
arrive après la petite dans les bras
s'est mise à pleurer ma plus des bras et
après s'habiller appelé ma mère qui sans
renier ce qui s'est passé à faire plus
tu veux réitérer ou pas
ça
ça chez moi
réfléchissez deux d'imaginer un comme ça
mais tac tac d'accord donc là c'est le
côté droit qui mange c'est pas le côté
gauche le côté gauche
elle a passé le matrix
mais avec la puissance
[Musique]
inquiète et ce qui pose problème c'est
que même en l'ayant acheté comme ça
elles n'auraient pas toutes ces
blessures alors soit vous l'avait jeté
plusieurs fois m c'est pas un drame
non dans le sens où elle est loin d'être
mauvaise santé va bien merci sauf
qu'elle a trois fractures et que ça
c'est inexpliquée pour l'ombre c'est
l'esprit ça bah oui mais il faut que
cela s'explique ça viendra vous ne
marquez pas de nous gaver klocker c'est
ma fille je l'aimais je voulais
récupérer mon but c'est pas de guerre
des nazis si j'avais fait une fois dans
ma fille je l'aurais dit je fais
beaucoup à l'hôpital pour dire qu'il
s'était passé çà çà çà çà çà sur le pas
qui ça j'aurai mon tissu avec l'équipe
du long et mon mari aussi bon ça c'est
clair et net te fais pas la chine est un
de ses maillots oui c'est vrai c'est
tout
[Musique]
17h retour au commissariat
oui bonjour c'est donc c'est un sujet du
bébé mais des petits génies appel le
procureur pour l'informer du déroulement
de la garde à vue on a été sur place
elle nous a remis mais tous nous ont
affirmé qu'un caméscope qu'on l'avait
déjà fait sur un autre dossier de bébé
on a pris des photos et mais elles se
prêtent alors ça c'est un petit peu
choquant après ça peut dépendre des
tempéraments et s'est prêté au jeu et
elle a remis mais la scène au moins je
sais pas combien de fois alors qu'elle
dit se dit que c'est pas byzance et puis
affecté mois nous a remis mais et c'est
vrai qu'on prend on a vu ça correspond
pas nous ça nous semble voilà
d'incohérent quoi
combien elle est allée très volontaire
alors tout à fait
alors c'est une dame très comment dire
elle et elle est prête à répondre à
toutes vos questions c'est
impressionnant et là il ya mon collègue
subvenir qui arrive quand on veut mettre
un mot monsieur est en train de faire
parce que c'est moi je cours en garde à
vue ce glyphe les bras le torse le
médecin arrive
voilà je tenais missionné l'époque est
d'accord très bien à tout à l'heure
madame sont assis là vraiment l'heure
[Applaudissements]
le père du bébé craque il vient de se
lacérer le corps avec une faune sedan
qui l'a arraché de sa bouche
comme ça comment voulez vous récupérez
votre
pc voit ça sort pas aller bien et pas de
code rien
il va boire un verre soufflé au ca sort
pas allez venez dégueuler dans les
chiottes sinon
bien en train de tout faire
pour vous tapez le bon gars je sais
je sais je vous en parle pas mais
la situation préoccupe les enquêteurs si
le père de l'enfant est hospitalisé le
procureur peut décider de mettre fin à
la garde à vue
vous m'écoutez j'étais en ligne avec le
procureur canton ne m'apprend que vous
faites le compte qu'est ce que je lui ai
dit dites-moi est-ce qu'on continue la
garde à vue est ce qu'on continue les
auditions jeudi au procureur qu'on peut
continuer
jusqu'au bout on essaie dans la vérité
si vous voulez pas continuer moi je vais
faire un garde fou c'est sûr vous
rentrez chez vous ce soir vous n'avez
aucune chance de récupérer cette fille
oui
finalement le procureur décide de
prolonger la garde à vue de 24 heures
encore trop d'incohérences à élucider
[Musique]
à
ton appareil
photo une
cartouche wen ont lancé au nom mais
c'est déjà super on n'arrivait pas du
tout aller à les sortir c'est génial
super merci super
c'est important pour vous d'avoir ces
photos ouais ouais ouais parce que je
n'ai pas encore vu la petite fille
qu'elle avait directement ont passé en
pouponnant ouais ouais ouais là vous la
regardez vous dites c'est pour elle que
je travaille ouais ok moi ça là par
contre
oui voilà
bon
c'était pas prévu ça
est-ce que vous pensez que vos faille et
votre force dans votre peau est
carrément on travaillait un équilibre
entre ma vie personnelle et défis culte
et que je peux rencontrer les blessures
que j'ai pu avoir les blessures que j'ai
que par définition n'a pas choisi ses
blessures là et mon travail et
franchement c'est mon travail c'est mon
équilibre pour être stable pour être
épanoui
et ce qui fait que le soir quand je
rentre plus je fais des affaires durée
va plus j'ai envie de serre et puis ça
me rapproche de ma famille quoi et ça
j'en suis convaincu
me ridiculiser là
[Musique]
[ __ ]
crillon et tu sais je suis en plein de
garde à vue là et oui purée kim cherche
ici à rien fait j'essaie de rien le sais
pas moi qu'ils ont trouvé un jardin
stéphane tu as peur de lui un
sais pas où je travaillais voulu
retenter rêve non je suis détendu
maintenant il faut que je continue mais
ouais c'est tout le temps comme ça fall
compte ici il faut regarder les portes
ou et des fois j'oublie on n'est pas les
sièges les sièges et souvent qu'ils sont
mouillés et puis là les téléphones ça
fait entendre l'a pas fait mais
téléphone à bord est tout noir les
conneries de gamin mais ça fait partie
du jeu la détente quoi j'ai remarqué
fred et guillaume vont essayer de me
faire rire et où quand il voit sur
certaines affaires que je suis touché
bon ça c'est évident qu'ils vont arriver
à un moment donné et qui vont ils vont
venir
ce soir virginie attend encore une
dernière visite
owen 10 ans vient chercher sa maman
là c'est cadeau de fête des mamans ont
nickel regardes et tu vas avoir dans les
bureaux des gars ils ont mis ce que tu
leur avait fait notamment des brosses
guillaume tu vas dire bonjour
l'école est finie
entre sa vie de famille et les affaires
de la brigade virginie a dû apprendre à
faire la part des choses
de
colo non mais brouille il va chez une
nounou avec qui ça se passe très bien
donc comme quoi j'ai des dossiers avec
des nounous mais la preuve que voilà ils
valent au centre de loisirs j'étais j'ai
eu des affaires avec centre de loisirs
il adore jouer avec ses cousins des
grands cousins qui sont ados mais me
maquille mais tout ça c'est des ados
lemmy 18 ans il rase tout seul avec eux
dans la chance je vais pas penser à
autre chose quoi sauf que vous et pensez
quand même parce que l'annonceur et j'y
pense parce que j'ai lu dossier dans la
journée c'était un cousin un grand
besoin voilà mais ça je vais surtout pas
aller lui dirai je laisse et puis
c'est mes peurs à moi comme tu prends
ton manteau city
21h les tâches se vident
le couple pas sa première nuit en garde
à vue loin de leur petite fille placée
en pouponnière
[Musique]
une épreuve pour ses parents suspect
mais peut-être pas coupable
là j'entre en garde-à-vue quoi pour voir
je veux qu'on sorte l'inde humilier
notre ambition d'époque rue dont
l'accroché pourquoi faire pour eux donc
j'attends
je voudrais qu'on laisse tranquille aux
dames la fille qu'on l'est qui c'est
tout car et puis c'est les voilà
prévenus sera menée chez bringueurs 2005
aux mamans effet tout 17
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon donc moi je suis madame thomassin je
suis avocat c'est moi qui vais vous
assister dans le cadre de votre
prolongation de garde à vue le lendemain
les interrogatoires reprennent le père
et la mère du bébé ont choisi d'être
assistée chacun d'un avocat
ont continué s'asseoir à dire la vérité
parce que vous avez dit que la tpu
puis on précisera verra ce qui se passe
c'est la paix
de leur côté les trois enquêteurs font
un point sur la sphère et stéphane
émettent une nouvelle hypothèse moi ça
me paraîtrait pas impossible qu'elle ait
le couvre son bain par exemple
[Applaudissements]
sechin un point mais non ça me
permettrait pas habituellement oui
qu'elle dise voilà j'ai fait comme si
j'ai fait comme ça qu'elle invente un
geste
pour être réel et correspond et qu'en
même temps et couvre les agissements de
son manque de personnalité quand ça va
passer quoi que on a plus grande marge
de manoeuvre il a par devait espérer
c'est de là l'idée ce serait de l'un des
deux craque quoi
oui mais là nos jaillir nos moyens de
pression n'existe quasiment plus puis
haletant qui joue pas en notre faveur a
entre guillemets seulement là on arrive
presque à la fin puis 48 heures c'est
court
pour faire retomber la pression michael
brand le verra pas
à aucun moment on a dit c'était vous ou
votre femme donc c'est pour ça que nous
on s'interroge toujours moi je me
détends mais le vtt je ne suis pas
contre eux non c'est pas ça je suis vous
savez je suis simplement pourri bv pas
possible ça parce que qu'est ce qui
arrive ça arrive à naxos aussitôt c'est
un excédent voilà notre cas maintenant
on garde amina piron c'est si on est des
parts au comblement
personne n'est pas un gamin de dix mois
c'est un petit on est constamment c'est
la première que je pris dans mes bras
29 heures de garde à vue et toujours
aucune certitude
virginie décide alors d'entendre une
amie très proche de la mer je pense pas
qu'elle ait fait quelque chose moi c'est
plus eux serait construit
et qui est faux à dire créer
des couches
un cador pu annoncer à son loyer aussi
raconte j'avais pas capable tous sont
qui met protéger internet par rapport
peur qu'on a un outil web je crois que
dans ce cadre
que justin qui soit
passager sa annonce un piteux on va dire
s'effacerait priorité donc
un nouvel élément ressort de cette
déposition il y aurait eu récemment des
violences dans le couple contrairement
aux déclarations des deux suspects
c'est la première ce qui quand même aux
dire que c'est pas aussi idyllique ouais
je sais pas je les reprendrai bien sûr
elle dit qu'il est gentil comme tout
mais enfin elle c'est un cendrier samedi
dernier sur la cuisse
il faut qu'il traque la fois là c'est le
dernier michael prend la relève et
entend une dernière fois les parents du
bébé qui l'interrogent séparément ça
fait vingt-quatre heures dans ça fait
même quasiment quarante huit heures vous
nous décrire votre cou comme un couple
tout va bien des peluches enceinte tout
va bien et non
c'est normal par contre lorsque woods
expliquer votre grossesse tout va bien
dans tout ne va pas bien depuis votre
grossesse est ce que vous vous
considérez violent nous
j'ai simplifié ma question est ce que
vous avez lancé un cendrier sur la jambe
non
pourquoi je suis posé des questions
vraiment très précises pour avoir
réellement ce qui s'est
passé non sens enfin madame manon pas
trop quand ça sort pas parce que vous me
dites pas les choses pourquoi vous
efforcez had me dire qu'il n'ya pas de
violence dans votre couple alors que des
témoignages disent le contraire aux
normes si la zone et moi comme les
cds
c'est beau
je n'ai plus envie
j'ai l'habitude pour vous énervez pas ça
pour tirer les choses d'accord là vous
voyez vous montez vite quand même
pendant la procédure on apprend plein
pas mal de petits fait pas mal de ti
fait que nous vous avez envie de dire
qu'un chez peut-être pas où on me dira
c'est le jeu par quand je dis c'est un
jeune ans pas un jeu ce que j'ai par une
petite fille de deux mois qu'elle trois
fractures qui ne sont pas expliqués
c'est pas un vain trois possibilités
c'est vous c'est pas vous mais vous
savez pas c'est pas vous mais vous savez
là c'est pas marrant mais je sais pas
[Musique]
contrôle
c'est quoi
on fait quoi
un coup d'état je pose la question on
fait quoi maintenant c'est beaucoup se
voient seulement
michael a su révéler les incohérences au
sein du couple mais il n'a pas obtenu
toute la vérité sur cette affaire
[Musique]
il ne sait toujours pas ce qui a pu
provoquer trois fractures à ce bébé de
deux mois
c'est normal regardez c'est normal là il
vient en aide c'est logique moi je tape
sur le clavier que ça alors je tape pas
sur les personnes ça si c'est moi qui
vais gt gt la chasse aux scoops
la garde à vue est terminée
le procureur a décidé d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire pour violences
volontaires sur mineurs de moins de 15
ans par ascendant
la mère a été mise en examen le père
bénéficie pour l'instant du statut de
témoin assisté
ils sont tous les deux présumés
innocents
[Musique]
c'est un moment de décompression safa 48
heures
c'est pas moi
c'est les nerfs qui lâchent un français
après un bébé cassé donc fracture est
quand même à la tête donc j'ai passé un
vol avec violence des violences
volontaires aggravées
là c'est quoi
[Musique]
ah ah oui des faits sexuelle pareil a
bien été gelé à la gare par cinq hommes
là j'ai du travail et puis je peux
continuer derrière et je peux aussi
répondre au téléphone
boya des mineurs bonjour bonjour laurent
savalou rend au chef et là ça tombe bien
on est avec les trois drôles de dames la
surcharge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la tempête
les semaines où sa bouche alors eu
besoin de toi là donc en effet on a fait
l'histoire du bébé donc on les a placés
en garde à vue mercredi matin et
viennent juste partir soit être déféré
pour une ouverture d'un faux et
franchement moi je trouve mais on a bien
bossé disons que je suis contente parce
qu'on a pas eu d'aveux cieux
d'explication pure mais on a apporté
tout ce qu'il fallait dans le dossier
quoi on était un peu dans le juge que là
vous et il lui a tant il nous a fait
tout un cirque dans la garde à vue il
avait des fausses dents trop il ses
griffes et partout cliff et le tout le
corps avec les dents en matant aurait vu
tories vue le 6 octobre à steph a dû
aller de calais mais tête contre tête
dans la geôle
parce que sinon mettais fin la garde à
vue et puis tu imagines c'était cité
dommage quoi donc
bah ouais c'est bien ouais tout à fait
c'est bien non franchement c'est bien
shari
s'écoula points
c'est bien combien ça mais c'est vrai
que ouais ils vont manquer le patron
bravo pour le silence
non mais ça me semble trop belle de
s'assommer n'ont failli aux
merlus c'était pas mal ouais ça
allait mais j'ai des cheveux la fif on
verra ça et puis bon le vieux je peux
pas et ça c'est pas qu'on cherchait pas
le temps
[ __ ] de courir immédiat qui a bien
repris ce soir appris hier que c'est un
fardeau ans non non
sur le moment sur le moment juillet tu
as créé la vie continue lens je crois
encore la vie
les gens n'en
pense que les gens sont capables de tout
soit je sois faire un grand père
voilà j'espère par tromper sans mes
propres hôtels
j'ai choisi pour mamie et voilà
jean j'y crois pas non
c est quand j'ai eu cordon
[Musique]
les uns de leurs nuits
au delà
les verts
on
il est
très drôle
en dehors de la voie
là
[Musique]
toute la vie
là bas
[Musique]
non
bonjour
[Musique]